>>> A STUNNING HEADLINE IN "THE
NEW YORK POST" CAUGHT MY EYE
OVER THE WEEKEND.
QUOTE, SON'S BRUTAL OBIT OF HIS
PLUS SIZED REDNECK MOTHER GOES
VIRAL.
THE IDEA THAT A SON WOULD TRASH
HIS DEAD MOM AND GO VIRAL FOR
IT, YOU CAN IMAGINE WHY I FOUND
THAT DISTRESSING.
THEN I TOOK TIME TO READ THE
ACTUAL OBITUARY IN "THE FAY
FAYETTEVILLE OBSERVER."
IT WAS NOTHING LIKE WHAT "THE
POST" WAS DESCRIBING.
HIS MOTHER WAS UNAPOLOGETICALLY
A FORCE.
HERE IS WHAT HE WROTE.
BECAUSE SHE WAS MY MOTHER, THE
DEATH OF ZAFTIG RENEE COREN AT
THE IMPOSSIBLE OLD AGE OF 84 IS
NEWSWORTHY TO ME AND I TREAT IT
WITH THE SAME RESPECT AND
REVERENCE SHE HAD FOR, WELL,
NOTHING.
A MORE DISRESPECTFUL,
TRASH-READING, TALKING AND
WATCHING WOMAN IN NORTH
CAROLINA, FLORIDA, OR TEXAS WAS
NOT TO BE FOUND.
SHE PLAYED CARDS LIKE A SHARK,
BOLD AND PLAYED CRIBBAGE LIKE A
PRO, AND LAUGHED WITH THE BOYS
UNTIL THE WEE HOURS, LONG AFTER
THE LAST PIN DROPPED.
SHE TOLD ME SHE CAME UP WITH THE
NAME FOR SUNOCO.
AND I CHOOSE TO BELIEVE THIS
TOO.
YES, RENEE LIED A LOT.
SHE LEFT ME NOTHING BUT THESE
LOUSY MEMORIES WHICH I AND MY
FAMILY OF FIVE BROTHERS AND MY
SISTER-IN-LAWS, NEPHEWS, NIECES,
LARRY KING'S CHILDREN WHO I
GUESS I MIGHT BE ONE OF, THE
TOTAL STRANGERS WHO ALL TO A
PERSON LOVED AND WILL CHERISH
HER FOREVER.
ANDY COREN JOINS ME NOW.
ANDY, I LOVE IT.
AND MY HUNCH IS, SHE WOULD HAVE
LOVED IT, AM I RIGHT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, IT'S SUCH AN
HONOR TO BE HERE, MR. KING.
AND WE'VE BEEN WAITING
PRACTICALLY MY WHOLE LIFE TO
MEET MY TRUE FATHER HERE IN HIS
TIME SLOT.
SO I HOPE YOU DON'T MIND WE
BROUGHT A PORTABLE DNA KIT TO
MAKE THINGS OFFICIAL.
>> YEAH, I DON'T EVEN HAVE THE
SUSPENDERS.
I MAY AS WELL GO THERE FIRST.
VAUGHN, PUT UP THE SECOND OF THE
PASSAGES THAT I WANT TO READ
ALOUD.
SO YOU SAID THIS.
COVID COULDN'T KILL RENEE,
NEITHER COULD PNEUMONIA TWICE,
INFECTIONS, BLOOD CLOTS, BAD
FEET, BREAST CANCER TWICE, TWO
MASTECTOMIES, TWO RECESSIONS,
MULTIPLE BANKRUPTSIES, SIX KIDS,
ONE CESAREAN, A FEW ABORTIONS IN
SPRING LAKE, NORTH CAROLINA, OR
AN AFFAIR WITH LARRY KING IN THE
'60s.
RENEE WAS PRECEDED IN DEATH BY
HER EX-BOYFRIEND LARRY.
WHAT IS THE DEAL ON LARRY KING?
>> LISTEN, I'M HERE TO FIND OUT.
WE'VE GOT TIME.
THIS IS YOUR HOUR.
LET'S GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS.
THERE ARE ACTUALLY RECEIPTS IN
MY FAMILY, WHICH IS A SPRAWLING
FAMILY, YOU KNOW, FIVE BOYS AND
A GIRL, AND MY MOM RAN AROUND A
LOT IN MIAMI IN THE EARLY '60s,
LATE '50s AND EARLY '60s, AND
SHE RAN AROUND WITH, YOU KNOW,
WITH THE BAD BOYS, AND GUESS
WHAT LARRY KING WAS.
HE WAS KIND OF A, YOU KNOW, A
DIRT BAG.
I THINK EVERYBODY KNOWS HIS
EARLY DAYS WERE NOT GOLDEN
YEARS.
>> OKAY, IN A GOOD WAY.
IF THERE IS SUCH A THING.
>> WELL -- WELL, MAYBE -- THE
STORY IS HE STOLE SOME MONEY
FROM MY MOM'S PARENTS AND THAT
THAT'S --
>> OH, JESUS.
HANG ON A SECOND.
HE'S NOT HERE TO DEFEND HIMSELF.
HERE'S WHAT YOUR MOM WAS GREAT
AT.
DYEING HER RED ROOTS, WEEKLY
MANICURES, DIRTY JOKES, PIER
FISHING, ROLLING JOINTS AND
BUYING DIRTY MAGAZINES.
SHE SAID SHE READ THEM FOR THE
ARTICLES BUT FILTHY FREE SPEECH
WAS REALLY RENEE'S THING, HERS
WAS A BAUDY, ROWDY LIFE LIVED
LARGE, BROKE, AND OUT LOUD.
I SHOULD TELL PEOPLE ON HER 85th
BIRTHDAY NEXT SPRING, YOU'RE
HAVING A NONDENOMINATIONAL
MEMORIAL SERVICE.
WHAT'S THAT GOING TO LOOK LIKE?
>> I HOPE IT'S GONZO, WEIRD,
LOUD, COLORFUL, FILLED WITH
PEPSI AND CARBS AND KRISPY
KREMES AND WE HAVE A REAL
CELEBRATION OF WHAT I'VE BEEN
CALLING THE QUEEN OF THE DIRT
BAGS BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT MY
BROTHERS AND I KIND OF JOKINGLY
REFER TO EACH OTHER AS.
BUT WE HAVE A LIVELY MEMORIAL
FOR A LIVELY WOMAN.
IT'S THE LEAST WE CAN DO.
IN A PLACE SHE TRULY WAS, WHICH
WAS B&B LANES IN FAYETTEVILLE.
>> TO GO BACK WHERE I STARTED,
MOM WOULD HAVE LOVED THE WAY
THAT YOU'VE MEMORIALIZED HER,
RIGHT?
>> OH, MY GOSH.
I MEAN, LOOK, SHE WAS AN ATHEIST
SO SHE DIDN'T BELIEVE IN AN
AFTERLIFE SO I CAN'T COMFORT
MYSELF THINKING OF MY MOMMY IN
SOME MAGICAL PLACE, THINKING AND
LAUGHING ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT OVER THE
YEARS OF WRITING ABOUT HER IN
VARIOUS PLACES, STORYTELLING,
PLAYS, ET CETERA, SHE ALWAYS
TOOK TREMENDOUS PRIDE IN BEING A
SOURCE OF INSPIRATION FOR ME, AS
ANY JEWISH MOTHER WOULD BE.
>> ANDY, WE'RE GOING TO SEND A
FILM CREW, MAY 10 OF 2022, TO
WATCH ALL THIS HAPPEN, OKAY?
>> OH, I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
REALLY GOOD MATERIAL.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE PLENTY
GONZO.
NORTH CAROLINA IS ROWDY AND
FAYETTEVILLE IS DIRTY, SO IT'S A
GREAT COMBO.
>> I'M LAUGHING AS I SAY SORRY
ABOUT YOUR LOSS.
THANK YOU, ANDY.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, HEY,
SMERCONISH, PEOPLE NEEDED A
LAUGH AND TRULY, I MEAN THIS,